THIS IS BUZZ SPEED.
BUZZ SPEED.
ALL RIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
BEEN ON BUZZ FEED.
THERE IS A LOT OF RIDICULOUS
LISTS OUT THERE HERE ARE A
FEW THAT YOU MAY HAVE
CLICKED ON BEFORE.
12 CELEBRITIES YOU DIDN'T
RELIZE HAVE LAZY EYES,
THAT'S ONE.
24 THINGS ONLY PEOPLE WITH
SMALL HANDS WILL UNDERSTAND.
THAT WILL BE ME.
17 FUZZY CATERPILLARS WHO
JUST WANT TO BE LOVED.
THOSE ARE ALL REAL LISTS
THAT THEY CAME UP WITH
MULTIPLE THINGS OF.
SO YOU GUYS WILL HAVE 60
SECONDS TO COME UP WITH BUZZ
FEED LISTS THAT ARE EVEN
MORE RIDICULOUS THAN THE
ONES ACTUALLY ON BUZZ FEED
AND FOR EACH FUNNY ONE YOU
GET 2 -- 2350-- 2 PO PINTS.
TWO BEST MOVE YEAUXES IN THE
TAKEN FILM SERIES.
>> POINTS.
>>> 12 THINGS THAT ARE
TECHNICALLY BLOW JOBS.
>> WHAT?
>> 10 OF YOUR FAIR RITH
FINGERS.
>> IT'S SO ADORABLE WHEN YOU
SAY T POINTS.
>> YES, KRISTEN.
>> OKAY, HOW ABOUT 250 OF
YOUR BEST SONGS.
26-- FORGET THAT ONE.
>> NO POINTS.
>> 8 FACIAL EXPRESSIONS CHER
CAN'T MAKE ANY MORE.
>> THAT WOULD BE A REALLY
GOOD ONE SHALL POINTS.
THAT'S LEGITIMATE.
>> NINE REASONS THAT FOUR
REASONS ARE BETTER THAN 12
REASONS.
>> YES.
>> AND THAT'S PHILOSOPHY
CLASS, YES, DOUG.
>> TWO VOICE OVER ACKERS
FROM BOB BURSERS WHO ARE
HORRIBLE PEOPLE.
>> OH, TAKING A SHOT.
NO POINTS DOUG, NO POINTS.
MIRMAN.
>> YES, 85 DOGS THAT ARE 24
CATS.